all right everybody it is time for the
450,000 subscriber giveaway video just
want to say thank you all so much for
all the support that you have given me
all this time it means so much to me
that you all have supported me for this
long I greatly appreciate it so thank
you from the bottom of my heart we have
so much exciting things going on right
now tomorrow is the Marvel Studios hall
age San Diego comic-con panel where we
will finally hear what phase 4 of the
MCU has in store for us so be sure to
check out my channel tomorrow so you can
find out the official face force light
of the MCU and the five hundred a
thousand subscriber giveaway the half a
million subscriber giveaway is going to
be even bigger I'm still going to be
given away the Marvel Legends items such
as the Captain America shield the Iron
Man helmet the Infinity Gauntlet but I'm
also going to be giving away a console
either a xbox 360 or a ps4 the winner
gets to choose which one he or she wants
the rules of that giveaway are of course
the same as the rules of this giveaway
you must be subscribed to my channel and
you must leave a comment with your
favorite superhero or villain also if
you want to follow my personal Instagram
cosmic Warren 13 I'll be giving away an
Infinity Gauntlet on there pretty soon
alright without further ado here are the
three winners for the 450,000 subscriber
giveaway alright the first winner for
the giveaway is Eli Alvarado Congrats
Eli shoot me an email in the email in
the description of this video to claim
your prize the next winner is the
YouTube user V Armageddon congrats on
winning be sure to email me in the
description down below and I'll get you
your prize and the final winner for the
giveaway is Aaron Collins Congrats Aaron
email me at the email in my description
down below and I'll get you your prize
as always the winners were picked
completely at random by a computer
program that I have as you just saw on
the screen but be sure to keep on
commenting on my video so you can enter
the 500,000 subscriber giveaway again
thank you all so much for the support
and good luck on the 500,000 subscriber
giveaway Congrats to the three winners
be sure to email me and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof